To help us see the need for caches, we'll examine
this little snippet of code. From an application programmer's perspective,
a statement like this one, the sum plus equals a
of i, would seem to happen in one step. Even
in assembly, it would only take a few instructions. In
terms of time on the clock, however, not all of
these instructions are the same. Sum, being a local variable,
is most likely stored in a register in the CPU,
therefore there is almost no cost to retrieving its value. a
of i, however, is in main memory, and retrieving its value
can take 100 CPU cycles. And even then, the bus bandwidth
might only be able to pass back two bytes a cycle
or thereabouts, to get the data back. Trips to main memory
are expensive, and this trend has only become worse over the
past few decades with hardware advances. The solution to this problem
has been to place a smaller, faster set of memory made
with faster technology, closer to the CPU. We call this
memory a cache. And here, we're looking at a latency of
about ten cycles. So, when the CPU wants the contents
of some memory address, it looks in the cache first. If
it finds the data it needs, great, we've just achieved
a factor of ten speedups. We call this a cache hit.
If the data it wants is not in the cache then
we have to go to main memory. We call this a
cache miss. The key is keeping these cache meshes
infrequent, so that on average, time spent accessing is more
like the time it takes to access the cache,
than it is like the time to access main memory.